[Music]
we stirred today's show with a touch of
class gliding through the woods and
Alexis's new hybrid engine sedan the is
300 H the luxury carmaker is hoping the
new range will help it replicate success
in north america across the pond
that forgive design clan said Alexis's
sandra Tibor says they have a
Development Center near Brussels where
various parts of cars are tuned to fit
the needs and demands of customers in
different countries the front of the new
bodywork is especially striking the
grille with large air inlets shows off
the brand's new look the cars just over
four and a half meters long small wings
on the door pillars and tail lamps are
designed to make the is more aerodynamic
with a turning circle of eleven point
two meters the car maneuver as well our
test driver Montes kirat is putting the
is through its paces
[Music]
he's testing the F Sport model with a
2.5 liter four-cylinder engine combined
with an electric motor together they
produce 164 kilowatts the car goes from
0 to 100 kilometres an hour and 8.3
seconds and has a top speed of 200
[Applause]
as a leash Mata says the is isn't very
sporty even though there's a dial that
switches the car to sport s or sport as
plus mode he says that when he tries to
take a corner with a bit more speed the
ESP kicks in
so either the ESP is too sensitive or
the chassis isn't quite balanced cm
Findlay wood about us found out this in
vision needs Alaska hold the Mantis says
the ergonomics are good all of the
important things are well placed he also
says the buttons are more graceful than
an other Toyota and Lexus models that
temperature control is particularly
interesting temple at worst our longest
finials endless under a joystick
operator for the entertainment system
takes some getting used to but Montes
says with practice it's not so bad a
real problem for him is the lack of
storage space the car starts without a
key and mathas had to put the key in the
drinks holder because there's nowhere
else at the front of the car to put it
Vanka a target on vaycay faunas on snow
Hawaiian blood Sabu whatever Dolph
boldness but Marcus says he does like
the fabric used on the front and center
columns and the ceiling he says it
creates a good impression
the Edward Kafei mother says he really
likes the digital console which shows
information on this ring it's controlled
with a button on the steering wheel
month it says it's just a gadget but a
fun lot I think it should be light so
how does the is measure up with the
entertaining and useful extras it scores
highly the most important fact for any
hybrid car is how much fuel it uses for
a sedan the figures are good the 300h
weighs one thousand seven hundred kilos
and uses just 4.7 liters of gas over a
hundred kilometers as for co2 emissions
the car produces a hundred and nine
grams per kilometer
Malthus gives his verdict on the is
Havas dusties I says in terms of the
design he's totally satisfied but when
it comes down to how the car feels he
says even the F Sport model isn't quite
sporty enough that's the kicker fit